hello everybody and welcome to episode
11 my pay the play flipping series we're
gonna go from zero to 100 mil using the
grand exchange only now you might notice
I already have some flips going here
that's just because I had the resolution
change and when I bought the clips was
on 1080p so I've since then switched to
this because it's easier to see happy I
will jump into it quickly here so the
dragon axes we unfortunate even on same
with the Asheville ruins we broke even
hunt as we only really made money and
two items so the Hellmouth needs not is
one of them and we got two point one K
margin each one and without sixty five
of those giving us about one hundred and
thirty eight K this you were attacked
freaking system there's always given
this a fifty one GP margin in two
thousand owes so one hundred and about a
hundred K from that alright so let's get
some new items going okay I think we're
any of the Asheville rooms another try
because we did buy them very quickly and
we should made money but unfortunately a
drop back down so we'll do another 10k
Astro runes so we actually managed to
instantly buy some super defense potions
um kind of biaxin I didn't think they're
gonna buy right away anyway we'll go
ahead and sell those pretty easily for a
nice couple under K profit
and last year I think we might do some
teeth logs actually it seems like they
have a forty TP Mars on them which is
pretty good now in the last couple
months they have been fluctuating around
a lot because the construction update
that guest came out or is planning on
coming out anyway but still they've been
tossed stabilized at this price for a
while so we'll go ahead and buy a couple
thousand teak logs is about two hundred
eighty okay so the flips are in and we
did pretty decent on a couple of the
items here so the Astra runes actually
did work this time I got five GP margins
on them and that gave us a boat 38 K
it's not so great but it was very quick
only took like twenty thirty minutes
these super defense potions we got
eighty two on each one and about 1900
about 152 K and the teak logs are still
in the process of selling now but we
should be making a pretty decent chunk
money on them as well
okay so let's grab a couple more items
that's with Astro runes type over the
four DP margin them still so we're gonna
do another 10k of them because they were
very quick and pretty safe so we'll do
them again next up we're gonna do the
helm of me does not looks like I has a
buddy 1.5 k margin on it which is pretty
good for the price point and we'll get
about 80 of them because they do they do
trade pretty quick so the flips are in
and we get pretty good on the energy
potion that had the teak logs and then a
helm kind of kind of okay but so the tea
clogs we ended up finally selling for
you thirty-five GP profit on each one
and we got by eighteen under logs that's
what 62 K now we only got ten Helms I
really only gave us what 6 K and the
energy potions however we got a book 422
K in profit we had to sell them in kind
of two different clumps but we have were
just pretty decent margin given us over
foreigner came profit so I can't
complain too much about that
looking at the buying limit page on the
runescape wiki and we noticed these gold
amulets have a pretty high buy price the
cool diamond strung so we're gonna go
ahead and try buy a couple of these
looks like I actually had a buddy 1020
GP margin which is pretty decent for the
price and I think the buying limit was
either 13,000 or actually no sorry is
like 20,000 that's what I was surprised
about
but yeah anyway if it is actually took
20,000 we'll be happy if we get that
margin as well go ahead and buy these
okay so we broke even on the amulets
unfortunately we sold them back exactly
oh wait sorry no we actually got one GP
profit on the influence
so that's 18k I guess or sorry 16 K
perfect and yeah the super energy
potions we caught a 400 GP margin on
giving this 644 K so I'm not too bad
then but I would the kind of hope that
some other items would do better but
let's go try and find them
it's not even that I want to do this you
French potions that badly it should be
like unethical not to do with them
because they just worked so well like a
500k one time 600 this time they just
instantly bought like whatever will do
them and well we've kind of struggling
to find some other items but we'll go
ahead and least try to get one more for
you okay so I think we're gonna try the
rune knife it has about a twenty GP
margin on it and it's at boat under GP
items so it's pretty pretty good for
what the price is and we'll go try a get
a couple thousand and see if we can
afford five thousand yet we'll do five
thousand yeah okay so the room knives
unfortunately crashed down a bit so we
don't got a 3gp margin on them so only
really got 6k from that have the energy
potions we got a about 500k from so yeah
kind of decent yeah so we'll go do a
couple more flips for this episode least
okay so the helm of new does not has
about a 2k margin and so we'll go by
about 70 of them and hope we just don't
hit the buying limit back
so through narrows actually have an 8k
or observe a k-8 GP margin on it which
is really good for the price in there
sold really quite a bit we've done these
in a while but we will throw it back
item and we actually were just kind of
selling some random dragon items in the
dragon mace has a 10k margin on it I'm
not sure how many of these are traded
per day but that still is insane margin
for at the price it is I have to assume
these are still used a bit I mean is it
still a dragon item so we're pretty much
just gonna use up the rest of our money
now we'll probably able to get like 20
or 30 of these approximately and I got
we'll check back in out of the morning
perfect so we have successfully bought
in sold all the items we wanted we got
the full amount which is nice it's all
green looks really nice so we'll start
with the the energy potions we did
another offer for those quickly you got
4 and 10k from that so it's nice the
bruton arrows were actually very
surprised and we kept it 14 GP margin on
them and we got 10,000 Romero's that's
140 K I would just really blargh for
that kind of item usually wouldn't get
nearly that much dragon mace we kept
about 9,500 GP margin on each one got 16
of those giving us the boat
and 52k in the Helmand leaves not we got
a 1700 GP margin on in 70 of them so
that's 118 cable I mean total we
probably got close to a mil on that one
flips that's very nice very successful
flips I'm happy with that
okay guys I think it's forgot I call the
end of the episode we had some pretty
massive progress today I mean we started
a boat a 9.1 mil and we're ending it
nearly 12 mil so in this episode we made
about 3 mil in progress I mean 50
percent that's probably just the energy
potions but still some of the other
items who try to have some pretty
massive margins on them as well as
always guys if you enjoyed please hit
that subscribe button to stay tuned for
the next episode and I will see you guys
in episode 12